[Applaudissements]
humaines auxquelles on assiste est
unique aujourd'hui les tennismen sont
comme des rock stars
votre porte et shawn oblige les gens à
se demander si ce juge notamment où le
rebelle mesdames messieurs
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes événement diamétralement
opposées n'est ce pas égrener 101 à bord
qui est en coulisses et une surprise est
ce qu'il va bondir de ça car il est pour
être superstitions les rituels j'te
kiffe mais pour eux c'est une petite
tradition comme tout le monde suit pas
une musique d'ac
on tique stan iceberg est en réalité
c'est un volcan en garde tous vents lui
[Musique]
vous avez votre héros votre gentleman
borg et vous fois vilain petit canard
comprenez c'est comme si on attendait
comme si c'est super et magique tu va le
battre ce soir
tout part comme si c'était facile allez
va si bien tu vas en faire qu'une
bouchée tu es le meilleur tu va le
battre c'est maintenant que ça se passe
[Musique]
tu seras le miroir ne se rappellera
jamais toi comme étant un grand joueur
tu sais pourquoi parce que personne au
thème serez vous capable de vous qu'on a
su qu'on ferme ta gueule
comme quoi les batteries bleus league
mais elle vous ignorez totalement ce
qu'il faut donner pour joindre des miss
j'arrivais quand je repars j'ai laissé
mes tripes sur ce but un court et ça
vous pouvez pas comprendre l'écusson
rochelle
je bois si toutes ces années avec l'idée
qu'un jour jacques cidre et ce moment
précis
[Musique]